what's up everyone this is the 10th
generation iPad we have the 256 gig
model with us and this thing was an A14
bionic chip so we're going to be running
some game tests as usual we're going to
be running Genji impact Call of Duty
mobile Apex Legends pubg and an apple
arcade game gear club before we get into
the games let's check the temperature
real quick so just start things off by
the way we are also on 100 battery oh no
we are also on 98 battery right now I
mean it doesn't need to be 100 you know
just to see how things helping out but
let's see starting off at about
28.6 nothing hitting 30 down here
all's good you'll be down here I'll hit
30 later on who knows let's check the
back let's check the back real quick
30 years down here
yeah you know we haven't done anything
to this yet so let's just get into the
first game and also before we start this
video is shot in 100 FPS so let's get
into it okay we're gonna start pubg
foreign
UHD is still not available so frame rate
is on Ultra
everything else is fine
and the aliasing I just just put it up
there why not Shadows enable brightness
yeah nothing else that needs touching so
let's just start again
but yeah so far playing with it
um I haven't really touched the controls
also this is it yeah
but honestly yeah so holding this iPad
it's honestly like a good size compared
to iPad Pro that we played recently so
this actually feels a lot more
better to play with it's more
comfortable
just a little bit more
all with the max
the upper the environment looks pretty
alright
I mean it is pubg so
I'm going through Ozark instead nice
I'm playing pretty well with this so far
these are the default controls so off
the bat it feels very comfortable to
play with especially the screen size
I haven't really experienced any like
major family drops so just you know
smoothness issues
okay so let's just look at the hollow
side real quick
okay that's pretty nice it the Shadow's
working pretty well as well as you can
see the sun is somewhere around the back
over there so let me shift it around it
reacts perfectly fine
well then fine actually it's pretty
looks pretty good
let's just go with that aerial quick
all right let's see how that means like
it's not a buggy it's pretty solid bug
is nice and yes
where a little bit
don't
there we go finally some of the kill
[Music]
ER
[Applause]
foreign
okay
we've been playing for about half an
hour now and oh let's do that
oh there he is
that was his kennel
this bottom
right am I right
I would have thought
two more guys
somewhere on here and there's one down
that side
jump down
got him
nice
[Music]
so yeah we'll take about a full match of
pubg and we are currently at
86 battery so that's 12 percent down
for a whole match on the highest
settings so honestly the iPad 10 gen
isn't doing too bad
like I said you won't be able to feel
much of a difference on the front and at
the back it's getting it gets a little
warmer by the minute but the thing is
it's not
hard enough to deal with uncomfortable
to play with so let's check the back
36 35
36.3 gets higher and higher 30 39
somewhere around here
oh yeah that's oh yeah a 40 all the
sides mostly
then let's check here
the corners 34-ish
yeah so honestly it's not too bad except
for the one spot it hit like 40 but the
thing is heat dissipates pretty well
across the surface of the iPad 10th gen
and at the front so you don't you won't
really feel
the difference there will be a huge
difference it won't be like oh it heats
up like say like the dexia 5 Pro so it's
actually doing pretty well so with that
let's just move on to our next game
all right so let's get into the next
game Apex Legends but before that let's
check the temperatures we're coming hot
off pubg and we're one percent down so
we're currently 85 battery
and yeah
heat dissipates pretty quickly on the
10th gen
it doesn't even go up to like 30 in the
lower versions
yeah
it doesn't even go up to 13 the low
region so it's not so bad
let's check it back
oh the heat has gone down pretty quick
look at that
all right so now that it's nice and
comfortable to play with not that it
wasn't before let's just get into Apex
[Music]
relatively quick setup let's check the
settings real quick we have the settings
I keep forgetting it's over here
so graphics
oh
all right now that we're in the settings
uh let's see original let's do that
Ultra frame rate
yes oh I can put an extreme HD so that
you can't do that so let's say we just
okay looks like I can't put Ultra in
original all right looks like a couple
of ultra though and
all right looks like I can't put
original and
right so it looks like I can put
original graphics
right so I can't select the original
graphic quality setting together with
the ultra frame rate so we'll just do
this because you guys want to see that
and see a depth of smoothie now just to
be a FPS sure why not
uh everything's on vsync or high and
you're saying boom whatever let's just
go all the way and confirm
let's set and let's just play again
I can't believe which phone it was but
that was something from where like uh
the frame rate would even drop in the
screen so let's just get them over here
yep
so as you can see enough really drops
the wall is
generating pretty low I'd say it's very
smooth experience so let's just get the
new thing real quick
so far so good
guys
I don't get it
that's whack
[Music]
[Applause]
it's enough I'm getting shot at
this point
where
all right so uh mid game check with a
couple engagements so far let's check
out how it fast temperature wise
from here 31 32 33 35ish
honestly like it seems high in a way yes
but it's not uncomfortable in any sense
of the word
check the back
that was an accident 34 35 no
hold on hold on hold on hold on
oh I got there
are they increased
oh you don't
know
[Music]
okay so let's just check the pack again
always printing
34 35 37
anything crazy here nothing crazy
36.35
so as you can see you know it's not
really heating up that much again this
thing is doing a very good job at heat
dissipation and we are currently at
79 battery we started off at 86 if it
falls right
so
not too bad
[Laughter]
it is
are there any sports left still here
let's go left
all right
so with that
I guess it's safe to say with the two
games we had so far apology and Apex it
can handle these VR games pretty well
and they all look really good as well so
let's just move on to the next game
before that
um real field tests you know honestly
it's not uncomfortable in any kind of
way even if you only check right now
it's still like 34 32 nothing is going
above 40.
that would usually be like
might indicator that things aren't very
comfortable so let's check the back
you see it's still about 33
nothing's even peaking nothing's even
going above 37 or even 38 39. so yeah
even here it's like 37 ish if I can find
that spot again but other than that
it's pretty doing the job here all right
so with the game one let's just move to
the next game and speaking of Champions
here's a message from our sponsor this
video is brought to you by MSI meet the
summit E6 didn't flip featuring the
latest 12th gen Intel Core i7 processor
RTX 30 series graphics and a 16 inch
Quad HD Plus touchscreen panel with a
360 degree hinge it lets you unleash
maximum productivity with up to 11 hours
of battery life at just 2 kilograms the
summit e16 flip offers unprecedented
performance and functionality allowing
you to work and play anywhere anytime
alright so coming in hot from Apex
Legends let's move on to call UT but
before that you know let's check the
temperatures as usual uh we are
currently at 77 battery it is going down
a little bit but not too much nothing
too drastic so let's just check this out
yeah as I said before the 10th gen
handles heat fairly well
the back
as you can see it doesn't take long for
it to actually dissipate heat so this is
doing very well
it's still it's a little bit longer but
it's more residual heat than actual heat
being generated from the device so it's
doing pretty good so let's play Call of
Duty
whoa
see
[Music]
all right let's check the things
okay
that's fine all right so let's go to the
graphics real quick and very high frame
rate on the highest but we can't go very
high on Graphics as usual you know so
we're gonna just do the steam real quick
so high and grab the quality maximum
frame rate Dynamic let's go to
multiplayer check something quick we'll
be playing one match so
I can't enabled as a fuel Ragdoll and
blue with
the high quality type thing so let's
just jump into a match because everyone
how do you just want to see frames right
let's just give your frames
and I do not want to play Frontline but
I guess I have to play fun right now
so that's fine
so Graphics looks pretty good as you can
see how the Sun reflects off the body of
the M4 it looks really good sights
you're all right as usual let's see the
knife
it's good motion is great
grenades oh never mind hold on
okay cool very nice
very smoothly so far
get down sniper wavy Recon ready for
deployment
orders
[Applause]
Target's in sight
and they're sitting
all right
[Music]
fine for the whole family
yeah just a bit more
it feels a lot better with the eks but
yeah that's that's a match so let's just
check temperatures there isn't much to
say about this honestly because it
handled Apex and touch the pretty well
but that's just a temperature
1 30.
yeah as you can see it's hardly breaking
the sweat with pop
as you can see
okay 29 30 29 as you can see the iPad
10th gen is hotly breaking a sweat when
it comes to Call of Duty so let's check
the back
yeah it's
it's nothing to complain about it's
doing its job it's doing really well
with heat management so yeah to the
touch it means just a little bit warm on
the top here but other than that you're
fine I don't think most people with the
other games you played as well would
have their hands over the camera anyway
because you all be playing like this
where it's on this flat side so yeah
it's the tension is hanging out so yeah
the 10th gen is handling itself pretty
well right so currently we are at
that's literally two percent down from
where we started this run so let's just
move on to the next game okay so coming
in hot from Call of Duty uh we're
currently at 104 still
let's just check the temperatures before
we head into gear club and
it hasn't changed much actually
it might have gotten colder
so yeah
there is no change whatsoever
as I said in the other part of this
video
the 10th gen is handling heat
dissipation pretty well so
yeah let's just set up gear Club
[Music]
okay
so
[Music]
let's Hold It Down
all right so far the game is pretty all
right let's
just skip this intro
actually
Graphics stick beautiful look how the
Sun puts off
the back of the car
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
so yeah it plays pretty well and I'm
guessing
I want to try the Altima actually I want
to get off my Romeo
let's do that and let's just get into
a race
let's go somewhere nice and sunny
all right
let's go
all right we'll check temperatures off
of this race and all that stuff so yep
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
handles
oh never mind
[Applause]
[Music]
oh boy
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
with that let's just check the iPad real
quick
honestly like by real feel
there isn't much of a change I mean it
is it has heaped it up just a little bit
so honestly it's also bad
check the back
[Music]
32-ish
after that uh 29 34 or 34 down here 35.
yeah but it's nothing that bad because
like I said it disappears heat pretty
well
all right so the type of gift club uh we
are currently at
70 we lost four percent in the last 10
ish minutes or so so
not too bad so with this done let's just
head on to Genji impact all right so
disclaimer we kind of waited for a bit
because there's some stuff happened in
the outfits so the time is different but
we are currently at 67 after playing
this for the last few hours and you know
after that one hour or two hours of rest
we're back in again and let's just check
the temperatures real quick
before we head into gentian impact
so as you can see it's a lot colder now
it's all cooler so you know if you're
putting it down for a bit to go do
something else and they come back to
play a game
some of the things you know if you're
going to put this if you put the iPad
down for a bit let me come back later to
play again
so the thing is you know if you're going
to put this down for a bit do something
else come back like an hour or two later
you're gonna expect it to be fully ready
for you
to get back to gaming and as you can see
you know the temperatures uh
pretty much stand it it's pretty cool to
the touch for the iPad so let's just get
into Genji impact
foreign
the world but before that let's just
check our settings real quick
so graphics
and let's go to the highest so let's see
brightness brightness should be fine I
think for now
let's see how it's like here
yeah all right that's fine just keep
that okay ready
okay so render resolution hi
High highest high high high highest 60
only
extrude I'll keep it high I do like
extreme motion below
hi hi okay this is on but we're not
gonna do that obviously so with
everything set let's just look around
first place we're going to go to
Instagram the monster anymore we're
going to go straight into Inazuma
so let's go there real quick
no this one here right there
let's see how long it takes a load
all right pretty quick actually
as you can see you know a little bit of
firmary drops here and there
and there we go let's look at our best
boy that looks and then
yeah it's looking pretty swanky
the details on his outfit that's pretty
good as you can see the lighting is
hitting off pretty nicely on this little
pin over here
it's pretty nice
because he's uh quite it's quite
apparent
when the frame rate drops it
[Music]
oh yeah
foreign
[Music]
let's just keep walking around for a bit
oh yes uh inazuma's obviously where the
ball density populated cities with NPCs
so
you know
as you can see there's a couple family
drops here and there so let's see how it
does well in combat let's explore forest
with that
now that's that's that's cool here let's
see what what happens when you find see
how the environment is like in a open
world set thing from a city setting and
then try to get into some combat
oh boy
look at that
all right oh okay that's bad
[Music]
never mind this is gonna be a fight
oh boy yep
[Music]
beautiful
let's see how all these like
[Music]
so
yeah you can see a very noticeable
freeway in jobs here and there whether
it's exploring or you know getting to a
fight so let's just hop into
hear this and see how it fast when it
comes to you know a large amount of mobs
in the space
you shouldn't let your guard down
yeah
right
[Music]
yeah
so honestly kid with big bumps like this
for some reason it's not so bad if it's
in a
smaller area like that
in a controlled area at least but when
it comes to larger open World areas you
know it does tend to struggle a little
bit
so the thing is you know like it's fair
to say that you know obviously you know
it's fair to say that this iPad is still
fairly new and a whole universe will
take a while to properly optimize this
iPad for genjin if you're gonna if
you're gonna get this iPad soon you know
without waiting for them to get it right
just forget
um just be prepared to see your family
jobs and everything and deal with a lot
of some optimization issues here and
there so other than that it plays fine
let's just check the temperatures real
quick
and like I said
oh I haven't checked it at all I'm
checking it now we've been through a bit
and heat dissipation is still
pretty good it's just like the iPad Pro
that we reviewed recently if you want
you can check it out down here but yeah
let's check the back wow it's it's not
even hot at all
and the thing is I usually expect most
devices to start heating up whenever it
comes against him but
yeah apple has improved quite a bit with
the heat disappeared technology
so with that let's get into our final
thoughts I think it's safe to say that
the iPad 10th Generation can pretty much
handle anything that's thrown at it
whether it's pubg or Apex or even Call
of Duty on the highest set things and oh
all the games look beautiful obviously
against you know it's not really so much
the hardware but more of the game itself
because you know it takes a while for
developers to optimize games like engine
which are graphically intensive for
newer devices like this iPad over here
so other than that this thing handles
heat pretty well I'm quite surprised
myself I think it's safe to say that
apple is taking great strides to ensure
that Hardware is able to handle such
graphic intensive games and improve heat
dissipation and all that good stuff
compared to other Generations that we've
reviewed before so if you have any
questions about this iPad leave them in
the comment section down below and I'll
do my best to get to them make sure to
follow us on all of our socials and
remember to leave a like And subscribe
to us it goes a long way and if you like
this video
check this out